[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais refuser tous les contrats faire
oublier
le type on lui offre une bouteille de
crémant il dit pas merci il dit OK
c'est quoi votre travail
[Musique]
personne non on est en danger c'est un
tueur sanguinaire ce mec
[ __ ]
tu as fait la guerre du Vietnam en fait
si je suis arrivé vraiment à la fin de
la guerre extrême fin à la limite
j'aurais même pas dû aller si c'était
déjà en train de remballer quand je suis
arrivé on sait qu'il a fait la guerre du
Vietnam aussi
[Musique]
ça sert à rien que je tapote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas possible de vivre avec
quelqu'un qui rentre avec un morceau de
rail humaine dans la poche